[Music]
it is a quter 5 welcome everyone to the
1715 colloquium powered by the eth
library whether you have joined us today
on site at eth or whether you are
following the event online we're very
happy to have you on board for this
evening my name is julan Julian de I
work at the E Library as a consultant
for research data management and I also
coordinate the data stewardship Network
at eth zich tonight it will be my
pleasure to guide you through this
evening I'll start with a short
introduction followed by the talk by our
invited speaker and after the talk there
will be time for questions from the
audience here in the room and also
online
and the event is also supported by my
colleague Sandra gwol who will be
monitoring the online chat for your
questions so what is today's event
about in the realm of data management
the fair data principles Open Access and
the reproducibility of scientific
results have moved Beyond Mia buzzwords
and there are many efforts now to
implement these guiding principles in
research environments across the globe
in Switzerland the Swiss Swiss National
open research data strategy was adopted
in
2021 and both in the E domain as well as
on the national level open research data
activities have gained ground one
measure of the national strategy also
aims to establish data stewardship to
support researchers in making their data
and code openly
available to follow International
standards such as the fair data
principles and many other activities as
the E Library we have in the last couple
of months worked actively to bring
together data stewards from various
disciplines and research groups here at
D ZK to build a network for data
stewards and also to highlight the
importance of their work and the
different role models that already exist
for persons with responsibilities in the
field of data stewardship at eth
zich and one of those persons is our
guest and speaker Today l shitz you lass
is lecturer at the department for
mechanical process engineering here at
eth surich and he's also data Steward in
the research group for Global health
engineering and within a pilot project
for data Stewarts that builds on the
Swiss University's action plan and based
on his work experiences he's convinced
that good research data management
should be taught through Hands-On
experiences and in a positive learning
environment instructed by peers in the
same
field and today L shubitz will present
to us some of the research practices
that are applied at the chair for Global
health engineering and he'll also
highlight how his role as a data Steward
facilitates this
work we we are very glad to have you
here today and I'm happy to hand over to
you so welcome
yeah thank you Yan thank you the for
joining us today julan I still need to
switch to my slides welcome onine for
those that joined us online as you
mentioned I'm in the group of global
health engineering with Elizabeth till
um I've joined you from the start so
Prof Elizabeth till Global health
engineering we started together three
years ago it's a
new and from the start I was hired
full-time as a data Stewart and today I
would like to talk to you about my
experiences and what I've learned in
these three years so
far so firstly please meet me a data
steart um this is my profile this is
what I am and what I'm
not um I have about 10 years work
experience now um five of those were in
research that was right at the start of
my career I worked a bit at AAR and
dubendorf and water
research um I claim to have these
qualities of empathy compassion patience
and persistence which I believe are
rather important as a data steart and
that model that we have in our group
because I'm in the interface of the
professor and the students and the
researches all the time there a lot of
conversations that I negotiate between
them so these uh are qualities that I
have and bring with to our group I have
an affinity for it largely because my
dad exposed me to computers at a very
young age um I sometimes say if it was
my sister who received the computers
then she would be standing here today
but it's me and I have quite a bunch of
teaching experience by now I feel very
passionate about teaching um and I
invest Ed quite a bit of time into
learning how people learn so
understanding how to build better
lessons how to build effective lessons
so that people actually walk away with
knowledge and
competence um after we teach let's come
to what I don't have um I don't have a
doctoral degree so I'm within this
academic system without a doctoral
degree I also don't have a qualification
in computer science I'm an environmental
engineer that's what I've studied in my
studies we had this tiny bit of C++ I
did enoy it
secretly um but I've never learned
coding from scratch right that wasn't
like my field I got into this by
myself I don't have a qualification
statistics either um that's not what I
do I don't help people build models
analysis I do the work before so when
they need statisticians or computer
scientists to help them they're there
for them at eth that's not me and I do
not have a lot of time but who really
has a lot of time right
so let's come to the 10 learnings from 3
years this is what I'm walking you
through this presentation there will be
10 learnings and I'm just going to tell
you about them um the first one is that
technology is not on our side um modern
Academia is a really highly demanding on
us technology wise digitally wise and
when you meet a professor who's already
writing GRS working weekends working
long sitting on Comedy supervising
students mentoring them the last thing
they really need is someone telling them
that they need to do something on top of
that right it's really hard to get in
from that side because what I see with a
lot of people in modern Academia is
challenges like overflowing email
inboxes right there's so much email for
everything it's hard to organize it
there's browsers with hundreds of tabs
browser management so much work happens
in the browser today the internet's
everywhere there's files stored on
desktops you know file management is a
bit of a struggle who's been taught that
really to do that
properly we've got so many channels to
communicate we've got Ms teams we've got
slack someone tells you to join element
there's a Nas there's a Google drive
it's really overwhelming right like
there's a lot to do for modern academics
credentials passwords otps 2fas PS don't
get me started right the amount of time
that people reset their passwords and
the amount of time that spend just like
resetting your password I'd love to like
look at that in terms of loss of time
that someone could do
work another learning I had is e1's
reproducibility I joined in 2021 and it
was really good timing actually but just
in 2022 about a year after my start
first of July 2021 is when I started
there was exactly a year after the
guidelines for research data management
were published we got excited we looked
into it we studied them we found that
the scope says that these apply to all
members of e including academic guests
that's a lot of people right when you
say all of eth Zurich involved in
scientific research here in
researchers we find under publication of
research data and programming code that
both of those must be published all
right that's stated there there are
guidelines and there are some
restrictions and loopholes we know that
but that's what eth really wants that's
what they want us to do and they want us
to do that in a fair
manner Fair meaning Fair data sharing
principles a very popular paper applied
almost everywhere by now from 2016 is
this about 8 years old and has found a
lot of adoption people like this they
like the concepts of it and they are
helpful so we got all excited right we
were so happy wow this is happening eth
we all going down the road of publishing
data and code and working on
reproducibility these terms are rather
technical in nature so the really mean
right what is undefinable it's all quite
technical right so you could assess
whether or not is something Fair they do
require data management strategies to
establish
workflows and it's really just not a
checkbox right like sometimes I see
people okay I'll just upload my CSV
somewhere and I'm done I'm fair but it's
not there's a lot more to it and again
it's not just something that happens
from today to tomorrow it needs a
strategy um that establishes workflows
and processes
and that's what we're trying to
do third learning is data management is
project management just like any
research group you grow you have a lot
of students there's a lot happening you
need some project management there when
we're looking at our group um and
looking at this plot here you can see
the number of Bachelor and master thesis
projects that we supervise over the
years we had about 40 this year and let
me add those are largely supervised by
two people the professor and the senior
researcher who both still almost every
week meet with their students right
there's a lot of work in there at the
student
level and that requires proper project
management that can't be handled by
email right you're not sending Theses
back and forth by email doing that that
needs data management which is part of
um what we consider part of
it what we have done for students is we
have published a vikii um um which is
public you could access it through that
link that anyone can read um and it
includes something like grading criteria
we have communication expectations in
the data storage and data management
guidelines presentation standards and
the ways that proposals for a project
and then the actual thesis writing
requirements are being
done this helped us a lot it really sets
expectations we very transparent about
how to work with us what I want to point
out from our grading rubric um is that
we have a section on data publication so
looking at these four main areas which
have 31 sub areas where people are
exactly told what they need to do to get
a grade between four and six or what is
a
fail we have one of data management
under research competence and it states
there that the student will receive a
six if the data is fully documented
organized easy to reproduce and
publication ready everything is stored
on Google Drive we're using Google drive
with our students I was very happy that
eth allowed us to use Google workspace
because it's very efficient for us to do
so
but the data publication requirement is
there so if students get a six in all 31
areas right all of them even this one
but they have not deposited their data
in a repository they would just get a
5.75 what they has done is like students
asked early I like okay what do you want
me to do there where must this go what
is this how can I get my six at the end
and I really motivated to do it right
and this is a way we've build it into
our Bachelor and master students that's
really showing a good effect now where
we're heading towards publishing data
from from their thesis and helping them
also build a portfolio that's a bit
different than those of other
students also want to highlight in that
context um looking at the open research
data position of the eth domain from
2020 about four years ago there's a C
that specifically points out that all
students and researchers in the eth
domain from Bachelor to postgraduate
should have access to training on
research data management we've really
included that into our strategy so we
are really starting at that level of
Bachelor to make them aware of this to
help them process progress through
Academia with that in mind from the
start rather than starting with the
senior scientists that are sometimes a
bit set in their ways right
another big learning is that
predictability wins you know sitting
next to people a lot and then you know
they're looking for a file and they're
looking in their email outbox because
that's what they remember there was a
time when I sent this email in July when
it was summer and I sent it to this
person so we building predictability
into our structure and naming
conventions on our
Drive um and our shared Google Drive
there's a shared Drive called GG
supervision which is very structured and
there's a set right there's no folders
ated you've got archive Bachelor Masters
if you head into the Master's folder you
get into the MSE thesis folder and then
every single folder looks like this
there's a nameing convention that
combines the year where the student has
started with the degree the type is it a
thesis or a thesis semester project and
their eth ID that increases
searchability in the drive and it's
really predictable where things are we
never really have to wonder oh where's
the data of that student everyone knows
everyone has access to that drive right
because we're working like very openly
within our
group um and that unique identifier that
we have for each student um each staff
right this is the same like for me I
have my own folder my my own unique ID
that's used in other places like if you
we use Soo for reference management I
have my folder there that has my unique
ID we we make sure we use this in
different places to identify people and
um learn where things
are this is a very important one to me
um low it Affinity is not a lack of
aptitude in the sense
that against common beliefs we try to
really enforce that there's no Gene for
coding there's no Gene for data this is
not born to you everyone can learn this
um and I think you know this is where
where today in computer science we still
have relatively low numbers of women
where there was like a common belief in
the 80s and we're trying to really get
that out of people that this is not
because they're not good right oh I
can't do this this is too difficult and
complex for me but focusing on making
and creating safe learn environments
where we focus on the growth mindset for
Better Learning outcomes being like I
can learn I can do this and that's
really a big focus in all our classes
and the culture in our group that no one
feels like they're incapable of doing it
because maybe someone has told them
before right maybe they've had a few
failures but yeah that's what we focused
on a
lot we do that through regular
one-on-one research data management
meetings so with our PhD students
especially I would meet very regularly
we have like standing meetings when
they're really in like data time I like
meet every week they come to me half an
hour 45 minutes with what they currently
need and we're working together through
the things always involving them even if
I'm helping them write things we have
bonly halfday team
where we include research data
management topics um coding topics
sometimes I give a class sometimes we
just discuss so we're creating these
environments where people can also
exchange and we have a yearly Retreat
where we look into our strategies really
deep dive into which tool is working for
us and which is not because we also
really want to just learn from the tools
that we have tried and then if something
doesn't work that's okay we try
something
else this is the class we teach um
within ma it's open to a few other
departments I always forget to how many
but it's called research beyond the lab
open science and research methods for a
global engineer it's a 4 ects class it's
currently open to Bachelor master and
PhD we'll probably eventually restricted
to Bachelor for the fact that we want to
start building
there um students learn about data
management file organization
documentation it's all part of it and we
focus on survey based research but what
we also do here is we give students
transferable skills so everything they
learn is through open source languages
open source software in a way that they
can apply these skills also anywhere
else we're really focusing on giving
students like The mindset that what you
learn here is valuable later for you and
Industry and Academia Etc and we're
fully independent of eth infrastructure
here we don't even have a Moodle for
this class we teach it through an online
website it's the same as where I'm
presenting my slides for it's always the
same um um
background tools that to compile
these um this is going to get a bit
longer this section data isn't equal to
data that's something I've noticed that
when we talk about data underlying a
publication when there's a journal
asking for it and I have conversations I
realize oh we're not talking about the
same thing here so we've tried to define
those for us um those are definitions
that I've partly borrowed from other
this but before I do that a short
disclaimer on what data looks like in
our group um we have small group we in
mechanical
engineering we have small data very few
megabytes no complex structures it's
tabular mostly the data is non-sensitive
we don't really worry about
patents um if there is personal data
like we do a survey and we have GPS
coordinates or people's names or really
sensitive information we have ways of
removing that and anonymizing it and the
topics are Waste Management sanitation
air quality so someone would
characterize this waste maybe it's a
landfill in Uganda would take
measurements of air quality would ask a
few questions so it's a lot of
observational data survey data that's
the data in our group and I'm just
saying I'm telling you that because I'm
taking you through the three stages here
and then a diagram that explains those
in detail and how we work on them
so the first stage we look at when we
Define what data is for us is um talking
about unprocessed raw data an
unprocessed raw data is the data without
touching it that's how it comes out of
your form out of your sensor wherever it
comes from in its original form and file
type for us it's often an Excel
sometimes a CSV but also others but it's
not too complex and not too big as I
said it's mostly just a few megabytes
we're not working working with terabytes
of
data we invest a lot of time then to get
the unprocessed raw data to process
analysis ready data and that's the
biggest part of my job when it comes to
writing computer code we do all this
with r I'll show you a bit later in the
diagram how but what we Define as
processed analysis ready data is the
data that is processed to prepare for an
analysis right it's may be merged it's
cleaned that's all documented now now
the analysis is ready but no analysis is
done yet that's what the student goes
with the researcher and then starts
writing their paper that's what they
need to figure out themselves right the
methods of how to analyze the data the
models to apply Etc that's up to the
researcher not me I get them from stage
one to stage two in a reproducible
way we then publish this as csvs um and
in the format of an R data package we do
a lot of work in the r environment
um yeah I'll say a few more words about
that in my next
diagram and then the third term and this
is what I always understood as data
underlying a
publication is the data that is the
result of the analysis so when I open a
paper and there's a box plot there data
underlying that box plot right and
that's the data I want because I'm not
going to try to read the bar of the box
plot to tell me what the median is I
want that separately stored in a CSV
file and that's what I always thought
people Meme and they say that but that's
the thing we are always in discussions
around these terms and
topics okay now we're getting into our
process um this is really what we're
trying to apply for the whole
group and it goes along the research
cycle from research questions to data
collection processing analysis ideally a
producible manuscript and the published
article and typically what we see is
from research questions to data
processing can take anything from like 3
to nine months paper takes a bit longer
right like three years one year
sometimes if you're really fast maybe
never but we invest a lot of time in the
beginning so that the data is set and
the data is clean and tidy and Analysis
ready the data collection generates the
unprocessed raw data I mentioned that we
don't touch we only touch with codes we
edit it and do the data processing and
then produce the processed analysis
ready
data all of this the unprocessed the
code and the processed data stored in
one GitHub repository it's all in one
place it's fully reproducible there's an
audit Trail you know exactly how you got
from one to the
other this repository is something
called a cff file which I relatively
recently discovered and it's a lovely
file it fully fits into the fair data
sharing principles when it comes to
metadata it's um very M it's machine
readable in a way that a lot of systems
now just pick it up if you have this on
GitHub it will be picked up and your
citation information will be shown and
the great thing is what you can add is
the Orchid ID from all the
contributors what we try to do here if
we out in Malawi and we're doing a
survey with 30 people we try to have
them get a Gmail email address sign up
for an orchid ID and add all those 30
people here to the data resource we're
trying to add anyone that has
contributed to that data being generated
lab
technicians doesn't matter anyone all
people that would never end up on the
publication if they're lucky in the
acknowledgements but yeah what does that
really mean now these people maybe
they've done 30 surveys in 10 years
right for us and then they can show that
they can show on their CV 30 data sets
that are published I've contributed to
that but let me get to the publishing
part and we all know citations are
important in Academia right that's what
we need that's we probably always need
that we can't get rid of that maybe I
would wish we could but you know we
can't but let's put citations into
Data what we do with a GitHub repository
it's archived on zenodo zenodo is a
long-term archive that's accepted
globally by almost all funding agencies
as appropriate never seen one that
hasn't mentioned it and most importantly
though it provides us with a digital
object identifier that then identifies
the data uniquely as a resource linking
it to the authors and contributors
that's what we need to track it around
the
web really nice is that this DOI from
zenodo and the metadata structure that
zenodo has with three clicks you've got
it into the E research collection it's
very fast it takes less than a minute
it's in the eth research collection it
says metadata entry only the library is
really fast at going through it it's
typically within a you get you know it's
published and what we do is we integrate
this with just another line in the Adobe
experience manager into our website and
have a data publication list right next
to our journals so now when you open our
website and you see Publications there
it says data and they're all
listed the processed analysis ready
data we turn into an our data package
which is fullon templated boilerplate
very straightforward forward there's
good packages for that in the r
environment that help with that it lets
people in R work with it very quickly
and efficiently um we also publish it as
CSV and Excel on site but it contains
all the metadata and p uh the metadata
and documentation which is then
published as a standalone
website that website is hosted through
GitHub Pages Standalone website just for
the data put like some analytics on
there so we see how many people visit it
Etc but it's it's like another product
from the data and that's what we use for
data
curation this the work of the researcher
right they want to write the manuscript
we try to do that reproducibly again
with code and data all they need to do
is call the r library that contains the
data produce the tables plots and models
which I said we consider the final data
underlying the publication which we
store separately as csvs in that same
folder go through the same process as
they different authors right this may
just be the PHD student and the
supervisor and we get a second DOI here
we kind of separate these two things up
because we consider them different types
of work it's very technical you need a
lot of data cleaning once it's here it's
really the intellectual work that goes
into
it hopefully that article gets published
eventually you receive a third DOI and
what happens when you get here right
everyone's biggest nightmare you want to
submit your paper and they ask you
where's your data like oh I okay now we
need to get through the data we call all
the people that have worked on the
project we done right you just site
yourself you site your manuscript that's
where all my code is for this paper
that's where the final data is you site
this one that's where the raw data is
and all the code that produced it you
finished and that's really where the
value lies I feel like every time I get
someone to that stage I'm like here copy
paste a sentence and you're done now we
also have seven places where the data is
published seven places where people see
your research right they look that they
can discover you your research is more
discoverable but that's mostly through
the
data this is where I'm getting to
learning hate that findable and it took
me a while but it's publishing for
humans and computers that's what these
criteria that are under the F actually
really
mean and this is a recent paper
published by our PhD student Sone who's
today so if you want to chat to her
after use the opportunity to see how
that experience was working with me
through this um it's recently published
um this paper and now she has this
section computational reproducibility
and data availability she lists the
software that she has used and sites
herself with two separate citations for
the raw data and process data and the
analysis code that produce the
manuscript we're
done this our website
as I mentioned we have the Publications
tab then a data tab that's where her
data is listed on our website that's as
I mentioned automation from research
collection because the stuff is machine
readable it works it's so nice every
time I'm so happy when I add an entry
there this is the ET research collection
automation from zodo again because the
metadata is machine readable
transferable between the one and the
other this is zenodo where the data
receives the DOI that's automation from
GitHub right there's no one doing manual
entries on zenodo you create a release
on GitHub get your DOI that's it it's
once again just one switch and one
release on your software on
GitHub this the heart of it our GitHub
organization Global health engineering
where the data really sits where all the
work goes in fully open source I
sometimes try from the start just to see
you know are you are you open enough but
sometimes we only open it at the point
where you know we submit the
paper but this made for collaboration
right this is made for us to collaborate
we use the issue tracker to prepare for
meetings Etc it's really nice it helps
with the project management a
lot and that's the website that's the
website that's compiled from the repo
that sits on GitHub again there
automation that's hosting it on guar
Pages as I mentioned you can install it
straight for r you have the data
resources all the documentation the Cod
and dictionary is available but we also
provide the downloads as CSV and
Excel it's made for
humans it's like this is it this is
where we can really show we can show the
data we can show examples using our code
people can copy the code this is where
we can talk about our data in Standalone
websites that's free right it's free
service like GitHub Pages allows you to
host static websites like that for free
this statement is 9 to5 as possible
comes a bit from what I said planned for
tomorrow today you saw the very
exhausted professor in the beginning I
do sometimes feel like if we
build these practices into the group
there is a way that we can gain a bit of
efficiency that's what everyone wants
right you want to be more efficient so
you have more time and then hopefully
not get onto another committee but
rather go home at
five because this professor plans for
tomorrow they hired me which I was very
grateful for um and we're working
together to be ready for these
increasing demands and requirements like
at some point we expect journals we be
like well if your paper isn't
reproducible and I can't verify it with
data and code not sure if you can
publish here right at least the
prestigious journals where everyone
wants to get to Nature science
reproducible reproducibility is got to
be there and she's dedicated Financial
Resources to this right I was instead of
a postto maybe I'm straight paid
straight from a budget I'm
Administrative Assistant that's what
she's
done my last one there's funding for
this so you know if you really want to
do this there's a lot of funding
programs that support that Switzerland
wants this there's a lot of strategies
for open data open research data Swiss
University Swiss wide just pointing our
two funding schemes here the Swiss
universities one which just ended the
open science one there's open Science 2
not sure at the moment whether it's 10
or 30 million or anything in between but
it's coming and watch this action line
if you're interested in what I do
because it's all about the
professionalization of the open research
data specialist and related Services
which is a lot of what this data
stewardship work is um there's a
newsletter you can sign up for um the
other one is the eth board who was so
generous to add on to this universities
another 10 million and between 2021 and
2024 they funded 100
projects right with about 10 million in
total we were awarded five of those if
you want to stay up to date on what's
happening there next sign up for the
newsletter um that's where you can find
it so these are my 10 learnings and now
10 takeaways from these 30 minutes and
with that I want to thank you and the
online audience for being here today
listening to me and I'm very much
looking forward to your questions thank
[Applause]
you thank you very much l for these very
interesting insights from your work and
how the research group you work in works
together as a team I would like to
invite the audience for questions um
there's also people online but I would
like to start here in the room if
there's any questions from your side um
to our invited
speaker
uh you can go ahead and let me know yes
I'll bring you the microphone so that
the audience can hear
you yeah L thank you very much that's
very impressive um the the work that you
do and the entire group so yeah
congratulations um to that um I'm more
interested in your kind of like what's
your what's your normal day can you
share a bit like what are the processes
I have the impression many of the big
things have been lined up and I think
that was a lot of work going into it but
now what is the daily routine at which
stages are you involved in Bachelor
Master doctoral seases like how how does
this practically work yeah thank
you so it's like anything in Academia
bit seasonal like spring term I teach
right I teach that class Bachelor master
PhD but we are very involved with those
students and they get a lot of feedback
with us that keeps me very busy in
Spring term aut term is a bit more quiet
that's where I do a lot of work for
these projects we were awarded which is
all a community of researchers that do
the same research as us we're trying to
bring those practices into our sector
that's what we're trying to do there so
it's like spreading it out a bit I'm
really like always triing something in
our group trying to put it out where
somewhere else outs that's a lot of like
strategic work that happens over the
year hoping that those students that go
through our class will eventually do a
thesis with us might write PhD proposals
with us so they're ready to work with us
as they start when new people come there
onboarding we have a very specific
onboarding plan what you saw is a Vicki
for students we have internally that's
not public but we go through like an
onboarding week you know join this tool
get that make a meeting with me let's
discuss this and I'm slowly getting them
in leaving enough space and autonomy for
them to decide a bit themselves when
they're ready but they know I'm there
they know I can help but everyone is a
bit different some people take more time
some people really want right they want
training so that's
like how I work generally with our staff
and
students and then it's like in the
daytoday interactions we have using a
chat tool called element instead of
email we have a zero email policy that's
a lot of sharing it's like trying to
engage people I share links we try to
discuss on them
organizing it's a lot more like daytoday
just like engagement on those topics and
you know even if one in 10 opens every
10th link I've want something right it's
like I overshare soone no that more more
than yeah and otherwise you know it's
often strategy with the with the
professor we talk a lot about you know
different strategies different students
need different
things um lot of
conversations sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't we've had failures
we've had a lot of failures like student
sometimes students take much longer
because I'm involved because they know
want to do it reproducibly but maybe
aren't there yet
like it's very diverse but there's a lot
of there's a lot of human contact I
would say it's really a lot of
conversations all right I'll have a look
to my colleague are there questions
online
already yes so we have one comment from
the online audience um so Nicholas Owen
finds it really interesting to hear
about the air R packaging of the data
and
metadata and he's asking if you have
considered to use the use of Ro crates
research object objects great which also
shows the provence of the data and how
it was
processed could you repeat the exact
tool that was mentioned r o
grades grades research objects crates I
also had to Google it because I wasn't
familiar with it I haven't I would be
very uh grateful if you could send me
the link so I could look into it because
I'd love to learn about it but haven't
yet now
it's a short answer
unfortunately okay so then we have
another question here in the
room um thanks for the talk um I really
like your your pipeline uh this this
slide where you where you show how how
this all fits together um as I've
understood uh your main tool where the
data lives is actually GitHub so I
wonder this works well for small data
table data and not um sensitive data as
you mentioned that your your main data
is but I wonder especially in the
context where you exactly don't have
this you don't you maybe have like very
big data sets you have sensitive data
maybe you have a postgress database and
you still want to use your tools and
integrate it in your your workflow could
you guide me through how that would work
in your in this context and whether it
would work at all yeah no absolutely it
would um I would just you know whatever
is the community standard as to the
sensitivity and how it needs to be
treated you can do it to that level as
in the Raw data stays in the database if
it's too big it's stays local if it's
too sensitive maybe even on a secure
server but whatever code you use to pull
it out of there the code can be public
right you got to be a bit careful if in
the code also what you mention right you
also need to watch out for sensitive
information but then from there your
code can aggregate the data and maybe it
is just the data underlying the
publication but that's
okay right it's like you still document
the process of getting it out of your
database maybe anonymizing it showing
the code of how you've anonymized it
maybe there are best practices in your
field on how to do that now you can show
the code that has done that and you can
prove we have and then whatever comes
out at the other end I would go to the
safety of the level necessary for the
data you have and maybe that is just
Aggregates down to you know whatever it
means but that's also okay but that
pipeline works the exact same way
because the data package stays the code
is there the um the code that later is
going into the paper when let's say you
call the r library that it brings the
data in that maybe your data is already
aggregated and you paste the table and
you're done right then that part is a
bit less but it's I would say it's the
same applicable there you just got to be
careful and apply the exact standards
that your community has established
yeah but we're
lucky this is open by default it's very
easy for us
yeah okay could I invite again the
online audience are there additional
questions not at the moment so more
questions in the room
yes so lar uh thank you very much this
was uh extremely brilliant and Clear
Talk um I I I I really like your
approach I understand that your data
Steward which is extremely close to what
is
happening in the in the
group so you uh work with the students
uh that the the professor links to you
work extremely close to the the projects
and the needs of the researchers in that
group
um uh
one question that I could ask is would
it be easy for you to change to another
to another group with the knowledge that
you have but I I want to ask it in in
another way um in eth surc there are
529 professors M and does every
Professor uh have
to uh train establish a data Steward
that is uh so well knowledgeable about
what the group uh and the need of the
researchers in the group is or would you
say also there is other ways to uh
approach for an a university like
VR uh let's say data stewards that uh
might not be only might not only fit for
for one single group but uh for several
groups or what what would be another
starting point yeah another another cont
context for a data St
Stuart unfolds his his his skills Etc
yeah than youut um to get to your first
point is it possible in other groups
with other
professors yes if the professor wants it
you know that that it's such an
important point if and if they are
willing to give up maybe if few papers
you maybe you publish 15 papers in
instead of 20 maybe a little bit slower
for a while
but then hopefully eventually the
quality will
increase um in terms of does every group
need a data stward ideally I would say
yes that would be great to see you know
maybe at e one could argue you know with
the amount of funding that groups get it
might even be enough financial resources
but I you know leave that to the
discretion of the professor of how they
want to use it I do think there is many
fields where one data stward can help
several professors
um we are extremely unique we have easy
data but we're based in mechanical
engineering we have an economist as a
Prof we have qualitative researchers we
have one mechanical engineer we like a
whole bunch of people we work
international in like International
Development in resource constraint
countries we have a lot of other stuff
going on you know that's not just
research research data
data where things I think look a bit
more homogeneous within the groups if
you have 10 professorships that maybe
address different topics but the data
and data structures Etc are similar I
could absolutely see how one data
student could support 50 100 students
post dos at a
time right especially if they would you
know engage in it in a way
that yeah it's still it can't be as
personal that's not possible right you
you can't be the bridge between the
professor and the student and that's why
I say the buying of the professor is so
important because often what I see is
like students see this phds we teach
research data management school I taught
a workshop last year and they approached
me after they're like I talked to my
professor and they said no I said yeah I
know um understandable as well because
of what I said in the beginning they
don't they doesn't want another thing
it's like I've done this for 20 years it
works just keep going don't change it
now like who are you and that's why the
buying is so important from the start
they need to like be open to that to
that change and when I started I said to
Elizabeth give me a year to see if this
even has a chance if it doesn't I'll
leave after
two after two years we do a fiveyear
vision and after five years I believe
we're at a point where potentially we
could even remove me and things will
continue and that's that's strategy
right and the group needs to have that
vision
so that's yeah my answer
thanks any other
questions um yeah so uh you talked about
the different data that is collected in
your group also tapped on qualitative
data um that would be question number
one how this is actually um handled in
that pipeline mhm
um and then maybe also can you share
your experiences I mean I assume you
also go for ethical approval um and so
is this uh clear to everyone uh
assessing your ideas beforehand and is
this appreciated also along these lines
I mean I would say yes but thank um how
do you document what you are going to do
I mean this is very clear the processes
that you have so I I mean to me that's
so intuitive to share that and how is
this appreciated by
evaluators thank you so we increasingly
including it in ethical approval
qualitative data or not so new proposals
we always put it in there um we take a
bit of a risk sometimes right the
projects where we haven't included it in
ethical approval then we still do the
publishing qualitative data is different
um we had a qualitative researcher
senior researcher that joined us um
where we went through the process of
publishing one data set as such and
already starts with how is the data
transcribed and you know what does it
look like and what tech document format
is that and we went through the
technical process and that work but it
left a lot of open questions so the
guidelines are still relatively rare and
qualitative researches by Nature they
learn to not communicate right what they
learn from people in conversations
rightly so it's very personal
information what the person have shared
it the same way if they know it was
shared publicly we asking ourselves
these questions and the way we luckily
can address that is through one of the
explore projects it's that just started
we're working with the
transdisciplinarity lab at
theosis um where we've just set up a
project to really dive into what does
that mean if we wanted to right and now
we do the interviews and all that and we
collect we like oh we're going to share
that data and then we try to see you
know where are all the roadblocks and
how can we consider them and then again
you know it's it's is it's
to the level of where it's sharable I
understand that the raw data of
interviews doesn't have to be shared but
there's a lot of other stuff that
happens in qualitative research after
that that can and that can also be
structured again and that other people
could
reuse so just trying to find the lines
of what's doable
thanks okay I would also have another
question for you so you talked about lot
about the cultural change that is
necessary and the you are very actively
driving in the group take everyone on
board on in in the processes uh that
you're trying to establish and I was
thinking about other actors that are
also relevant in science like journals
and Publishers um I was
wondering is is it clear for the
journals and Publishers when you say oh
we have already published the the raw
unprocessed data and also the processed
data um is is that uh a problem for any
of the Publishers or journals have you
ever come across an instance where there
was trouble with the data already being
available before actually engaging in
the publication thanks that's a it's a
really good question um because we talk
so much we haven't published that much
yet I was just really so stoked that I
have at least one example to show um but
it's it's an interesting one because for
me this is part of how Publishers and
journals work with editors and
reviewers so I consider you know if if
it's not clearly described in the
policies and we look for journals that
have open policies right so we try to
not go for the journal that's most
restrictive on embargos and you know you
kind have had this published somewhere
else as soon as it says that we're
trying to avoid that that's like our
filter kind of you're already trying to
Target the journals that are more open
there's a few indices for that that help
identify it but then it's like you know
at the stage of the reviewer and they
see our sections you know I would expect
the reject from the reviewer to the
editor that says they're violating our
Journal policies you can't have
published this
before we haven't experienced it we
haven't published a thousand papers but
that's where I would like to see it
where also data data management code
becomes part of the review process
because what I currently feel like and
see we've analyzed one journal in our
field it's not even really looked at
right there's a there all data is
available in a
repository and then it's like a tick
mark or they've done that and no one
really ever opens that and that's the
the step I hope for you know that gets
there and then if they come back to us
and say oh you've published it there and
that's a problem and kind of happy that
they've actually figured it
out
yeah okay any other questions
yes one more question
here
um I have been wondering uh for quite a
while if it's easier to get into a role
somewhat similar to yours uh when you
come from the um data side maybe with
the deeper IT background data analysis
whatever or if you uh grow out of the uh
subject research actually and then
acquire the uh additional uh
competencies in in it and data analysis
and stuff like that the background of
the question is
also that after you have uh you have
stressed the the communication part um
quite a bit and I wonder if the the term
data stward might actually be a bit uh
misleading for for some people who
expect I have to be a data analyst to
even touch any data or uh come close to
that role would you comment on that yeah
well thanks um Matas I get that question
quite a bit and I do think a lot bit
about it quite a lot too and that's like
I seem as a very different from a
research software engineer or from a
statistician who are very highly
qualified in the fields and provide like
and it's sad but mostly a service sadly
right we we would love that to be more
integrated I think often like you want
them to start early you want them to be
more involved but just like how the
services even are they're mostly
separated in institutions so that's why
I think what happens a bit is when you
come out of that field and you now try
well you know join a group as want to be
a data stward there's a bit of a blind
spot there's a blind spot from thinking
that everyone can easily do that right
it's like when you have spent your
entire life in computer science software
engineering
statistics you have an expert blind spot
and you don't know what a beginner
doesn't know and that's easier for me
because I was a beginner not even 10
years ago I Haven it's not even 10 years
ago that I've started learning r i was a
beginner and I know what it felt like to
be a beginner and what took the journey
to get me at least proficient to do
exploratory data analysis meaning making
a few plots in Tiding up data but that's
where a lot of the work lies right in
the
group and then it needs this specific
support it's okay we're writing some
software we need statistics here so it's
it's a bit hard to say for me and in our
group it worked much better this way I
think having done research is
important having worked a bit in
research having had exposure to
different fields to different types of
data because if you're just stuck in one
field and you've only ever worked with
one type of
data that you know then you you well
then you might as well be a
researcher but yeah it's there's no none
is better than the other right it's
everything as I said you can learn
everything and there's so much capacity
in order of us to adapt to different
roles um for me it was easier and I
think you know it's I think what I could
see is that people that are in Academia
for a while but they like I don't want
to get onto that academic track I don't
want to have to do two years postto here
travel the world do an assistant
professor here get tenure publish get 10
Grands but I want to stay in research
because I find it fun and I like it I
love being in research this like
knowledge creation I like it but I don't
want to do that right I want to be in my
office I want to go home I don't want to
travel anymore and I think that's
something we can do like we can help
those people acquire the skills for data
stewards
more easily maybe than the other way
around but I mean they obviously both
work and it feel specific we have field
is not very computational the other
fields are very computational I would
struggle much more in a more
computational field was like
bioinformatics or but then again those
people are naturally more inclined to do
this right they don't necessarily need
that
support they you know if you come there
they know 10 times more than
me thank you thank you
okay so then that would be my final call
if there's any remaining
question otherwise I would very much
like to thank you once again lar for
giving us an insight into your work as a
data Stewart uh it was a very
interesting evening and I would like to
thank everyone who joined us uh who have
withered the snowstorm to come here to
eth um or who joined us online and so
that I don't forget anything that I
should say I'll pick up my notes
again I would like to add that this was
the final edition of this 1715
colloquium um but eth librar will
definitely inform you about an
Innovative and new event format why the
known eth Communication channel channels
in due course so you can definitely look
forward to future events and we would
like to invite you who are here to an ow
and further exchange if you want to and
otherwise have a nice evening and see
you soon hopefully here at
eth thank you